[Musik]
willkommen bei einer weiteren
sternstunde religion
früher nannte man die welt prediger ihre
aufgabe die religiöse betreuung der
rekruten und das leiten von
gottesdiensten zu bestimmten anlässen
heute heißen die armee seelsorger und
kümmern sich um die persönlichen und
existenziellen fragen der vielen männer
und der wenigen frauen die der schweizer
um ihr dienst leisten
bei ihr ist jetzt matthias reformierte
theologe und selbst während vielen
jahren ohne sorge scheint herzlich
willkommen
matthias rieger erinnern sie sich an
ihre erste begegnung mit dem apache
selbst in dieser kurzen schule eintrifft
sind ja weil ich mich sehr wohl
das wort eigentlich keine optimale
begegnung
ich komme mit einer persönlichen sorgen
weil jemand wie das aus meinem umkreis
fest erkrankt ist
ich sagte ihm dass und sagte ja meine
frau hat auch viel kopfschmerzen
das war dann auch mein letzter besuch
beim zelt kritik das hat sich heute
verdient war dass sie auch der aussage
dass sie selber gesagt haben ich werde
später selber eine sorge und werde meine
aufgabe anders interpretieren das wort
des lauf des lebens der mich so für das
war nicht rächen sich mit dieses ich war
nicht traumatisiert vom lief begegnung
ob es auch keine optimale und zeigt dass
es heute anders gemacht wird sie waren
ursprünglich primarlehrer musiklehrer
haben dann erst später eine ausbildung
zum reformierten theologen gemacht und
sind dann armee seelsorger geworden ist
die lautet eigentlich der die
militärische auftrag die armee die sorge
die armee beschreibt im dienst elemente
65 klar vor dass jede religion
respektiert wird in der armee
und dass man auch mit menschen ihre
religion respektvoll umgeht wird auch
ein glatte stellt für soldaten und
soldatinnen die nicht zur christlichen
religion gehören wo dann essens vor
schwestern die europäischen börsen
fester notwendige praxis
beschrieben wird auch was für
möglichkeiten gibt die armee legt wert
darauf dieses dieser welche religion
diversität optimal entgegen zu kommen
sie bietet daneben auch die armee
seelsorge auf die für alle news in der
nähe offen steht
jetzt gibt es aber wohl nicht nur einen
militärischen auftrag sondern es gibt
auch einen kirchlichen auftrag bis heute
ist es so dass die landeskirchen
entscheiden wer wird an diesem tag und
wenn ich wie lautet in der kirche
auftrag ziel zu sein wichtiges
handlungsfeld wird diakonie
früher war das nicht so närrisch wird
mit dem feld predigers das heißt heute
mit armee sehr sorten ist das nicht mehr
so wie schon alles gedacht worden ein
diakonischen auftrag wo die kirchen auch
große stärken haben weil sie es erst
erfahren sind und gute
ausbildungslehrgänge haben das sind
geeignete leute die sie schicken der die
software das heißt das predigen steht
heute nicht mehr im zentrum das
verkündigen ist heute nicht in eine
zentrale aufgabe wie die armee seelsorge
heute in der schweizer armee
funktioniert das haben unsere wesen
kollegen von rts in einer reportage
festgehalten um die kaserne von roma
trikot
ich finde es gut dass jemand von euch
fragte das ist eine schule fürs leben
gelernt hier viel über euch selber zum
beispiel die hier mit frustrationen
umgeht mit dingen die euch mein kollege
muslim der katholik oder protestant ist
das ist mir egal solange er morgens
pünktlich zum appell erscheint und wir
keine liegestütze machen müssen
ich finde es gut dass es diesen vorsorge
gibt
wir sind ja doch mindestens 300 tage
lang hier und es ist gut eine
längerfristige perspektive zu haben
wenn es mal nicht so gut läuft und am
nächsten tag noch immer nicht dass wir
dann auf den seelsorger sehen können auf
den arm edv erzählen können
ich könnte ganz friedlich sein fragen
wozu braucht es dann die theologische
ausbildung könnten wir auch einfach
psychologen psychologinnen seien die
seelsorgerische ausbildung auch diesen
dienst an den angehörigen der anderen
leisten können warum eigentlich dieses
religiöse elemente die hat ein
ausgezeichnetes konzept zur bedeutung
von diesen mitgliedern von dem soldaten
oft ihren weg heißt es liegt einzig
logische pädagogischen dienst es gibt
ein sozialdienst und es gibt die armin
seelsorge und wir arbeiten und gut
miteinander habe ich besonders im
auslandeinsatz erfahren dass man da
einfach komplett mit der einnahmen dazu
dient es gibt momente wo ich als
seelsorger einem soldaten empfehle aber
nicht beim pädagogischen dienst
abtropfen möchte weil ich denke das wäre
die richtige adresse aber die armee sei
aufgebraucht weil wir ganz genau weiß
die ganzheit des menschen besteht aus
emotionen aus biografischen erfahrungen
aus geschichten die man vielleicht aus
der vergangenheit mit nimmt die ganzheit
des menschen besteht dabei auch aus
konzertierenden beziehungen kann sachen
religiösen beziehungen
sie besteht
weitere auch aus dingen die einem heilig
sind
das war klar
in unserem leben und jede armee jedes
spiel zu hause das gefängnis auf schulen
wie man diesem auftrag menschen in ihrer
ganzheit zu begleiten wie man sich so
war in dem sie am ehesten software das
spiel 1000 sorge rinnen anstellen
also wir sind unersetzlich trotzdem noch
einmal das feld wo sich psychologisch
und seelsorgerisch aspekte mit dem armee
sensorischen religiösen teil überlassen
ist ja immens groß was ist mit oder was
haben sie persönlich wie erfahrungen
ganz spezifisch glaubens elemente
religiöse elemente in ihrem dienst zu
tage getreten sind
es ist so dass da jemand mit ethischen
fragen kommt und sagt ich habe jetzt
plötzlich müde bei der schießausbildung
oder master kommt jemand zu mir und sagt
ich weiss der mit kameraden kameraden
einen raum haben wo wir beten können
wir finden das einfach nicht koalitions
helfen das sind so religion spezifische
fragen aber es ist dass der zugang zur
armee sollte der speziell ist zum
psychologisch pädagogischen dienst da
muss man sich anmelden über den
dienstweg mit fast visite auf der messe
entsorga kommt sich vorstellen am anfang
des dienstes gibt vielleicht sogar seine
handynummer und dann kann man ohne einen
dienst weg zu beschreiten
wien zu einem ombudsmann gehen einfach
mal abends um viertel vor zwölf eine sms
schicken und sagen ich bin der unter und
habe dieses problem aber ich möchte mit
ihnen reden und dann reagiert die armee
seelsorgerin unter der medien sorgt
diese zugang ist sehr
einmalig im gebildeten schweiz und wird
von vielen mädchen ausgesetzt war nichts
für anonym
auf das einmalige begegnung können sich
vielleicht vorstellen
intensiv mit dem intercity von bern nach
zürich fahren
und da gibt's so ein kleines thema sind
nicht eine weiche kaum ein zinsen
fordern
der rekrut einfach hingehen kann er
kennt denn der hauptwahl sorge nicht
er muss nicht der browser in den namen
sagen wenn ich gefragt keine gemacht und
er kam hundertprozentige sicherheit
haben hier wird nichts weiter geleitet
der geht das nicht passieren das bleibt
hier der armee sei es geht auch nicht in
der befehlskette war ein richtig sein
steckt oder schlichte aber muss
seelsorge geheimnis strikte waren hatten
sie eigentlich selbst einen widerspruch
verspürt zwischen ihrem verständlich von
christlichen friedensethik und er dienst
natürlich haben sie das gerecht es sieht
menschen in der armee
sie spielten diese widersprüche auf und
weil ich diese videos ja auch spüren
kann ich das ganz gut mit ihnen auf
versprechen und ich verstehe sie auch
sehr gut
unser berate auch im auslandeinsatz so
ich bin vier jahren sehr oft war kann
man innerlich backen zu diesem
widersprüchlichkeit sie haben als teil
der kv truppen auf dem balkan
auch da haben sie erfahrung gemacht
einerseits mit den wert sind das auch
mit speziellen situationen die anders
verlaufen erscheint in einem wk in der
schweiz und andererseits auch diese
multireligiöse multikulturelle situation
wie sind denn die selbst und ihre leute
damit umgegangen
die truppe selbst die sogar dem die dort
sind die soldaten und offizieren die
dort sind dezember den ich sehr oft
entweder christlich oder konfessionslos
der muslimische jüdische egoistisch sind
alle religionen vertreten und das gibt
sehr interessante begegnungen und klein
anders diese dialog findet ob die
wahlweise saisonstart statt
bei bier oder bei uns im container wenn
man zusammen spricht und austauscht dass
dieser dialog findet statt
aber wann ist man natürlich auch in
einem gebiet wo es viele verschiedene
religionen gibt und da bin ich dann aber
immer freiwillige angebot gemacht eine
moschee besuchen zu gehen zusammen oder
ein orthodoxes kloster das in dem viele
mitbekommen hat ganz gute gespräche und
auch in der armee gibt es so dialog
situationen jetzt ein comic ikonen und
er vielleicht einen strukturellen thema
nämlich wie sucht die armee überhaupt
personen geeignet sind für die armee zu
entsorgen
wir haben hier auf der homepage des
eigenen parlaments
verteidigung bevölkerungsschutz und
sport eine große praktisch gesehen die
sagt wir suchen geeignete personen für
die seelsorge ist es so schwierig
geeignete personen zu finden dass diese
interessen scheinen ja diese
seelsorgerin und versuchen können sich
einfach aus den öffentlich rechtlich
auch nicht kommt und kirchen rekrutieren
es gibt natürlich auch seelsorge von
öffentlich nicht anerkannten kirchen zum
beispiel aus dem karton pappe kanton
genf es gibt auch ein aus zwei touristen
die diesen dienst leisten
ob die können sich nur aus diesem
kirchen wegradieren die erwartungen sind
auch ein masters in theologie oder das
heißt menschen auffangen
die methodistische pfarrer
beispielsweise armee sorgen die müssen
auch die bewilligung zum beispiel der
reformierten landeskirche dann haben das
entscheidet die armee aber dies ist eine
vortrag gebracht wird
und dann müssen sie eben ein master
mitbringen seelsorge ausbildung und das
etwa ihre landeskirche sie auf schickt
für diesen dienst
jetzt hofft man ja tendenziell zu wenig
förderlinien und gar nicht alle sind
sehr begeistert vom gedanken der armee
oder art messias vor gericht zu werten
und einige haben auch nicht zeit weil
sie das mussten den vereinen und
kirchengemeinden müssen ja auch engel
und englisch und pressbaum als erfreut
sich kein verein oder kirchgemeinde laut
dann jede fahrerin oder fahrer bremste
dann noch drei wochen im jahr ablesen
hier funktioniert die landeskirche
ähnliche unternehmen diese debatte der
zurzeit gerade am hochkochen dass die
unternehmen zum teil nicht mehr freude
haben denn wir wissen dass die männliche
belegschaft noch drei wochen unterwegs
ist sich weiter mit
da funktioniert auch war die
landeskirche genau gleich sie könnte
doch auch ein interesse haben ihre leute
da hinzuschicken damit sie auch einmal
leute erreichte die für uns leben nicht
erreichen wodurch die sonst nicht zur
kirche gingen die interesse haben sie
das ist glaub sind ochsenpost sagen sie
haben europas ist ganz klar ihr
commitment zur armee sorgt
sie finden zu weniger aber sicher ganz
persönlichen wir hatten jetzt die
fachlichen voraussetzungen auch die
persönlichen menschlichen
voraussetzungen damit man diesen diesen
dienst leisten kann in einer doch sehr
vielfältig gewordenen armee lernte ich
das kennen
da gibt es ja
humanistische sales ort gezeigt 1964
haben die fast 40 kommunistische zwtl
sorgen und haben keinen täglichen weg
hinter sich eine universitätsstudie
gehört zu einem humanistischen verbund
von roland das gibt der katholische und
reformierte armee seelsorgerinnen und
seelsorger die 1200 zwei muslimische
zwei jüdische und die können alle um auf
jede frage zu sprechen kommen sie müssen
alle das gleiche können
in der interaktion mit der person die in
ein gespräch kommt und so warten zum
beispiel wissen sie gut zuhören können
offenherzig sein land zu müssen die
perspektive wechseln können sich also in
die schuhe des amtes stellen können
wissen wie sich das anfühlen muss oder
welche phasen diese person genau hat für
mich ist das ganz klar ein von mensch zu
mensch dienst werde sehr wenig dann mit
religion zu tun hat sondern mehr mit der
frage können wir aktiv zuhören abwies
intuition sind die tolerante menschen
haben wir auch humor tragen die hoffnung
in uns also eine breite palette ab das
zentrum für die frage was ist
demgegenüber von mir jetzt die größte
sorte aber es ist die stimme von mir
besonders heilig
ein soldat hat mir einfach gesagt sollte
ich heimat sterben müsste unbedingt ein
snowboard an meinem grabstein gebootet
werden hätte ich ja sagen können
mitgeliefert so brachte man sterben
nicht wo noch weit weg zum tresen wir
dann vor der auferstehung vor christus
das hätte ich wenn ich mit meiner größe
müssen den koffer wäre hätte ich das
gesagt habe ich selbstverständlich nicht
gesagt haben ich höre auf die russen
meines gegenübers und ließ ihn erzählen
was dem sofa kanal ist an bord
das ganz interessantes gespräch wir
wollen geld ein malkurs anhören die sich
denn die schweizerische armee und die
abgesehen sorgen selbst positioniert wie
muss ich auch sieht und wir haben dazu
den schweizern seelsorge stefan jung
jahre vor gehst stand heute gut
aufgestellt
noch meint dafür haften kann die armee
sorge die allermeisten bedürfnisse und
anliegen der angehörigen aufnehmen und
in eine gute richtung lenken
es wäre aber fast gesagt wenn ich sage
wir können jetzt welche bedürfnisse
erfunden das können wir sind ab und an
nicht häufig aber es kommt darauf
angewiesen dass wir auf fachpersonen
anderer glaubensrichtungen außerhalb der
armee zurückgreifen können
längerfristig scheint mir ist das
vielleicht für eine gute wahl
es wäre hilfreich und dienlich wir
konnten bereits auf eine interne leute
zurückgreifen die sie kennen die die
armee kennen die wir geprüft haben die
wir ausgebildet haben und mit denen wir
einen guten aus austreten
sie kennen sich gut auch als paar
kollegen als der gleichen region wie
sehen sie denn dass die schweizer armee
ist wie nie zuvor multireligiöse
multikulturell aufgestellt wir haben
eben gehört es braucht immer wieder in
bestimmten situationen auch das
zurückgreifen auf potenzial und auf
ressourcen die außerhalb der uni zu
suchen sind
haben sie solche erfahrungen gemacht
diese erfahrungen sind sehr selten
aus einem audi mutter eines muslimischen
rekruten gestorben ist
glaubte ich dass ich auch erst begleiten
konnte dann wäre es wahrscheinlich weil
noch einige wochen rekruten funktion vor
sich hatte optimaler gewesen hebt er
jemanden zu finden wird mit der frage
des traumwagens und kommt mit tot
für den 20 jährigen jungen mann aus
muslimischen contact der hätte
wahrscheinlich optimal werden können
das war eine solche situation oder in
dieser situation dann aufs personal von
außen auf irgendwelche mama oder münchen
gelernten von aufenthalt zurück ließen
oder wie den konkreten der situation
umgegangen er selbst das war dann auf
seine ressourcen passieren
abgemacht dass ich einerseits mit seiner
billigung dem kommandanten orientiere
dass er den schwierigen situation ist
der topf nicht selber tun gab mir den
auftrag
sonst machen wir das ja nicht und wir
haben wir auch gesagt dass er in seinem
umfeld
jemand habe wo es am wochenende hingehen
können was eine notlösung
jetzt ist es ja grundsätzlich so dass
die armee muss die religiöse wird auf
der einen seite aber auf der anderen
seite eben der anteil an den
konfessionslosen an den säkularen oder
atheistischen anteil so zu sagen dass
wir auch steigt wie geht man als
religiöser seelsorger mit dieser
situation um das sind ja so wie die
großen trends sozusagen
ja das muss man wissen das ist was ich
erwarte von jedem armee offizier der
armee sorgen dass sie kontext bewusst
arbeitet und es sind tatsächlich
durchschnittlich das weiß jede vierte
person ist konfessionslos diese zwar
dürfte bei jungen menschen zwischen 20
und 30 jahren gelöst zu sein
dieses komplett bewusst uns da sein aber
dass die praktische erfahrungen als ich
einmal in der adventszeit so ein
kerzenlicht gemacht habe im
auslandeinsatz als eine zu wieder kommt
am schluss einfach gesagt
du eigentlich habe ich mit der firma
nicht viel am hut
ich könnte die das überlegen ob ich
wieder in die kirche eintreten möchte
aber körper kontextsensitiv recht gut
umgehen
diese situation aber konsequent zu ende
gedacht bräuchten wir in holland auch wo
man ist diese sehr sorgen der damit
diese bevölkerungszahl der größe wird
vielleicht von 25 auf 35 abwechseln der
nächsten zeit auch vertreten ist
das ist eine offene frage nicht in die
bereits diskutiert in der abend wird
nicht diskutiert
aber ich habe diese diskussion nicht
jeder hat es sogar einige abschreckende
griffen den gedanken dass es eine
gottlose sorge geben könnte
ich hab doch das schicken wie geht man
dann ganz konkret jetzt mit den
bedürfnissen anderer religiöser oder
eben spezifisch vielleicht auch
jüdischer oder christliche hinduistisch
angehört er in der armee um wenn es
beispielsweise um feiertage geht wenn es
ums essen wünsche geht wir leben ja in
der regel in der öffentlichkeit vor
allem die schuhe als dieses große
integrations feld und bekommen darf auf
diesem kontext auch auf die konflikte
mit aus der armee scheint es da bringt
zumindest nichts nach außen gibt es
diese konflikte nicht oder hält man sich
einfach keine interne die werde nicht
hinter die haben die gibt es praktisch
nicht oder selten
ich habe aber eine studie eine umfrage
gemacht bei 22 muslimischen armee
angehörigen der schweiz und die chancen
also umso kommandanten unsere
vorgesetzten war da immer sehr
konziliant wir haben gute lösungen
gefunden wie man mit diesen fragen essen
feiertagen welche und praxis umgehen
kann
das sind sehr oft nicht die armee sorgen
weil wir zu sehr auf die vorgesetzen
kommandanten die bei einem wirklich
ausgezeichnete arbeit in diversity
management leistet
was heißt das jetzt ganz konkret wenn
sie den bedürfnissen nachkommen dann
gibt es koscheres essen gibt es essen da
gibt es weniger kostet
wie weit geht in die vielfalt ganz
praktisch seit die hier nicht so weit
hessen gibt es in der regel nicht aber
das nicht aber es gibt bestimmt in sehr
vielen militärischen einheiten und
schulen und diese bücher habe ich selber
sehr positiv erleben sind sehr
vielfältiger sagt zum beispiel aus
vegetarier
dort wurden zwar auf eine ausgeglichene
ausreichende kost gerade jetzt in diesen
tagen hat der islamische fastenmonat
ramadan angefangen
wie gehen die muslimischen rekruten und
armee an werken in dieser zeit an ihren
dienstherren und vor allem was haben
diese erfahrung in dieser zeit in dieser
besonderen herausforderung auch gemacht
zwei dinge die zu sorgen erstens gibt es
ja nicht nur praktizierende muslime
sondern teilweise taxierte und nicht
praktizierende muslimin
auch in der schweiz das ist das erste
was gesagt muss einige praktizieren das
sehr distanziert und das zweite ist da
kommen einige daher und sagen ja die
haben vor wechseln zum schule mitunter
haben gesprochen
er hat uns gesagt die wie das tun können
ich kann die ganze geheimnis und wollte
die sie auch nicht hilft aber da sind
sehr pragmatische leuchte dahinter von
klinischen seite gibt sehr gute
ratschläge erteilt die allem an
funktionen und dann gibt es noch
austreten
das bewahrt muslimische soldaten sagen
ich habe dem küchenchef gefragt dann
noch überlegungen das außerdem baut und
doch aber daran sonst und dann steckt er
uns noch was zu machen also ein sehr
hübsches diversity management
es gibt eine dokumentation auch auf der
website einsehbar heißt es unter anderem
es steht den kunden oder den
armeeangehörigen während des
militärdienstes die möglichkeit zu ihren
religiösen bedürfnissen außerhalb der
arbeitszeit nachzukommen es wissen ja
die arbeitszeit ist natürlich auch den
christlichen rhythmus unterstellt wie
gehen jetzt beispielsweise muslimische
armeeangehörige mit dem video ist um am
freitag beispielsweise ein freitagsgebet
abzuhalten das würde ja dann innerhalb
der christlichen arbeitszeit mit dem
sonntag als ruhetag fallen viele
kommandanten und die sagen dasselbe wenn
jeder mit dem sachsen bedürfnis kommt
finden wir lösungen
das wäre eine große ausnahme wenn man
keine lösung findet könnte und suchen
dann pragmatisch um 10 offenbar auch
christliche armee seelsorge gefragt die
auf solche lösungen dann umzusetzen
wissen dass wenn jetzt so eine winzige
gottes an einem freitag des dienst
aufgehalten werden soll
da gibt es ja dann keinen muslimische
seelsorger oder ausgebildete personen
die das macht ist denkbar dass zu einer
form der leyen das ausleihen
organisieren werden
es ist der schweizer armee sehe anders
aus dem armen die sehr viele
auslandeinsätzen operationen genannten
gebieten haben die schweizer medien
nicht übers wochenende zu hause die
soldaten und die kollektive religions-
praxis findet in den usa praktisch nicht
statt
es gibt keine gottes christlichen
gottesdienst einige wenige noch und dass
ich natürlich alle die nicht gehen
möchten sind natürlich die spin sie
jetzt davon aber das ist ausnahme man
nicht heute auch in der ausbildung als
war medien sorgen so wird wert darauf
dass man mehr auf in puts auf schlechte
wege leiten
oft sei das anna befürchtung style oder
auf einem mast begleitet 30 kilometer
marsch oder im dorf zum tag habe ich ihm
auch im auslauf einsatz habe ich immer
am morgen bei arbeitsbeginn habe ich
kein wort zum tag
dort kommt es darauf an dass man nicht
exklusiv sondern inclusive spricht am
alter denkt die hier sind und das heißt
also dass eigentlich die interreligiösen
kompetenzen bei den armee seelsorgern
und vor gewinnen sehr hoch lang ist also
das wissen um die andersheit der
anwesenden die muss startet oder
mindestens die intuition richtig darauf
zu reagieren
ich denke damit zusammen haben beide die
situation so darüber nach dass die
konzeption der arbeit die malaysia sorge
gut bedacht werden muss damit man eben
nicht exklusiv sondern inclusive
arbeitet damit man die religiöse
landschaft tatsächlich auch kennt und
damit man fest auch ressourcen
orientiert arbeiten kann
beim gegenüber bei dieser person die zu
mir in eine beratung und in ihrer
dissertation ganz gerade angesprochen
geht es darum eine einschätzung
vorzunehmen wie es um den
christlich-muslimischen dialog in der
schweizer armee sorgen steht wie kam die
auch das thema was hat sie daran gepackt
gab es einen schlüsselmoment der welt
was der internet initiative ich war
damals im auslandseinsatz und zwar
sofort
da bekomme ich so ein bisschen zu denken
und brachte mit eigentlich meine kirche
die reformierten kirchen des reagieren
auf den christlich-muslimischen dialog
in der seelsorge und dann begann ich zu
lesen die statements und interviews zu
machen zu fragen und theologische
grundsatz bestimmungen herauszufinden
und märkte diesem dialog spricht nichts
entgegen von reformierten seite gibt es
nicht mehr
zu wenig gemacht das wäre besser gewesen
weil diese art ein zusammenarbeit sehr
wichtig ist die katholische miete
zusammenarbeit neu seit 2004 auch mit
dem kreis katholiken
aber ich hab's reformierten geschrieben
deshalb habe ich hier aus fährt play
einfach hause von mir zu sich
geschrieben um nicht für die katholische
kirche zu sprechen
aber die ist ohnehin auf seit dem
zweiten vatikanischen konzils wird sich
sehr für dialog freund ich jetzt höre
ich aus ihren reden dass es zumindest
aus theologischen erwägungen heraus
jetzt keine widerstände geben müsste
wenn jetzt auch darum geht
andersgläubiger in die arme so erni
seelsorge zu integrieren
aber hand aufs herz kann sieht sich
selbst ein interesse haben sozusagen
dieses monopol auch auf der hand zu
geben und andere für diesen dienst
zuzulassen
eine gute frage die sich auch in den
nächsten jahren jahrzehnten zeigen wird
ob das fell sorte monopol auch in der
schweiz bei den kirchen bleibt oder ob
sie einfach eine mitarbeiterin sein wird
kann ich keine prognose stellen aber die
frage ist auch so wie sie stellen ist im
raum ist unbeantwortet
sie selbst sehen sie dass also die gibt
es eine klare notwendigkeit dass
beispielsweise muslimische seelsorger
mehr seelsorger ihre einem festen
bestandteil der ami ausmachen sollten
wenn muslimische angehörte gesagt so
schön geschriebenen in diesem fragebogen
den ich gegeben habe es wäre so schön
wenn dir das zu die zusammensetzung des
seelsorgeteams so bund werde mit allen
religionen drin und das ist so dass der
große regen bogen gottes hat einfach
viele farben und die vielfältigkeit
unserer gesellschaft ja durchaus auch
etwas positives und bereicherndes und
schönes und man muss sich da gedanken
machen dazu auf sich so dass leute die
diesen diensten bis jetzt auch
erleichtern
ganz klare kriterien erfüllen müssen so
wenig geeignet aber nicht nur jüdische
hinduistische ob muslimische seelsorge
der wissen diese auch christliche aber
das ist ja jetzt schon so also da könnte
man sagen dass sollen die gleichen
kriterien für alle sein gibt es denn
aktuell in der schweizer armee
ein beispiel camille abily und wir haben
das einfach diese sorte aus der
katholischen der reformierten und der
christkatholischen kirche mit sie haben
wir die situation auch eine große
aufmerksamkeit in unserer nachbarländer
und auch allen und zugewandt und auch
zum beispiel bosnien und herzegowina
oder auch südafrika und dem gelände um
zu analysieren wie eigenes tage stand
der dinge ist punkto multireligiöse an
die seelsorge ist das vergleichbar oder
sind an einem anderen ort beispielsweise
in bosnien das geschichtlich gegeben
dass ein orthodoxer und katholischer und
ein muslimisches chef der am gleichen
tisch sitzen und die militärische
begleitung organisiert und das ist
einfach gegeben auf bevölkerungsanteile
in rom an zum beispiel nicht
ausgewachsen aber gab es früher das
letzte zweiten weltkriegs einfach
katholische und reformierte dann sind
die humanisten dazugekommen und
humanisten und beim spätabendlichen
jüdische und muslimische seelsorge sind
dazu gestoßen
das wächst jedoch demographie und nicht
jede armee reagiert gleich schnell auf
diese bio demografischen veränderungen
was denken sie wie das bei uns vor ihnen
damit zehn jahren aussehen wird wissen
sie es gibt doch muslimische hauptmänner
autos
offiziere sonst in der schweiz media
islamwissenschaften vergleichende
religionswissenschaft studieren wenn sie
nach einem cas besuchen in der seelsorge
und integrierte menschen dies andauert
turbomotor sprechen
sie werden dann ganz klar den diesen plg
arte diesen lehrgang der armee für
nächstes jahr 20 22 24 aufgenommen
werden ob ich bin da nicht zuständig
kann wie das so vorstellen weil das
diversity management die sensibilität
der armee sehr fortgeschritten ist für
diese fragen stellen sie sich vor 100
jahren
die katholischen kantonen reformierte
ganz schwer angeschaut wurden bisher
nicht akzeptiert wurden war der
schweizer gewesen lange ein katholischen
und reformierten seelsorgers zusammen
hand in hand im dienst doch keine sorge
das hat gut funktioniert
ein schönes schluss dass sie uns hier
präsentiert haben und ich höre daraus
dass sie auch der ansicht sind dass
diese vielfalt weiter geht und auch
künftig in der armee ihren niederschlag
finden wir bedanken uns bei ihnen ganz
herzlich macht das weniger für dieses
schöne gespräch wie die zunehmend
individuellen wünsche nach religiösen
und spirituellen ritualen gestaltet
werden können zeigt jetzt unter finden
die ehemalige pfarrerin gisela tschauner
bietet heute als drei ritual begleiterin
ihre dienste für menschen an die
segnungen rituale und feiern außerhalb
der kirche und außerhalb des
christlichen glaubens suchen
[Musik]